this video is brought to you by manscape
comm manscape is the only men's brand
that is dedicated to the below the waist
grooming and hygiene they are the
perfect tools for your family jewels
hygiene is a really important issue
right now as we all know and if you're
using the same trimmer on your junk as
your on your face that is nasty
disgusting piece of crap I don't do that
anymore
good gentlemen now let's see what's in
this beautiful brand-new box it is brand
new oh oh nice packaging huh a nice
package with a nice leather case yeah
and this one this is why we recommend a
lot more 3.0 trimmer by manscape oh look
at that
oh it worked right out the box it's
built with advanced skin safe technology
which means no Nick's or cuts on your
coconuts
aka that's Hawaiian for testicles so we
encourage you to go ahead and get the
perfect package essential kit
oh is it right it right here the law war
trimmer 3.0 and everything you see here
you see this and you can get a new
replacement blade delivered to your door
every three months so you can get a nice
clean shaven ball sack whenever you want
and they have ball deodorant so after
you shave you can do two eyes your balls
some people really need that it doesn't
smell like balls you would think a
product that is used on the balls would
smell like balls what it's the opposite
if you want your balls to smell like
pine furniture this is exactly what you
need it's fresh it is pine fresh yeah oh
that's good
smells like man to simply just visit
manscape calm and then enter our promo
code JK news to receive a special 20%
off discount plus free shipping that
sounds good
really good we're gonna
the link in the description below so go
ahead and click that and get that your
balls well thank you and whoever else
enjoys your balls will also thank you
after you shave you could use the ball
toner lemon heard about the scandal Iza
$75 for pants that should be the scandal
those ones are really good though I've
never been able to buy one like I would
go in there cuz I want to buy a blue
tried them on no I felt it on Ryan is
really [ __ ] good you know what I
bought them over like four or five years
ago
and there's they still look new yeah and
they still last so I fell ten dollars
north I bought on on Amazon also ten
years ago they still fit pretty good at
guess what you could've bought seven of
them my old cheaper shorts and all that
they're all destroyed like a
[ __ ]
but then my Lululemon stuff it's still
good I think Joe say that you don't
train hard enough due to your shorts
body nothing like I 90s done to I want
to want it right so I keep going to move
around Oh put the fitment is honestly
really really I got a discount like no
job three times and I'll pick it up in
my hands and now look at the price and I
go I can buy four other shorts at Target
right now and I know every time this man
is me this is a break apart though what
are you 23 years old you and you end up
spending more money because you have to
buy more short at this point well guess
I know where the dozen charts that are
better than them and I'll give you say
Navy shorts red shorts blue shorts green
shorts yellow shorts
I bought some on Amazon they're really
good like really good so and their feet
good they yeah they're really it is
shorts weather it is I want shorter
shirt I'm wearing shorts in like a
couple months it's actually warm no
the older you become don't you want your
shorts shorter ya do with the short
shorts that come back though they are
covered I saw I saw an NBA like I by the
era is like short like how short and
long they are and like mm knit the
longest and then now whenever in 2020
its back up again the realtors are
wearing your already shorts now you know
why it's because um I don't like it to
hit my knee hey they're like when you're
running or whatever and then I have
short legs so I realize I look pretty
stupid in shorts that go to the knee
makes me look stubbier I look like a
child yeah that but we used to complain
about short shorts and anything that
wrote too high that it would like like
stop our circulation and our balls or
something like that which isn't true I
used to wear shorts like a does and he
has up to the ankles all right so the
reason I bring up little lemon is
because like Bart said there's some
scandalous things happening Oh still
design very good short stuff come off it
the senior the senior global art
director of Lululemon that sounds up
there yeah so he's uh he's up there in
the company he's a senior staffer he had
promoted these designs on his IG bio
like the link for these designs and then
this the guy that created like the
designer he posted photos of it on his
IG thinking it was great
so it's called bat fried rice tea the
box is no thank you
I'm laughing at how [ __ ] heinous this
is wait let's leave this up no thank you
this doesn't even seem like Lululemon
[ __ ] like yeah this is like Urban
Outfitters like this is free time right
yeah
is because he is a senior staffer at the
company cookie poke he promoted this via
his IG biolink because some fuckboys
walked into Lululemon and it was it that
design I've been like this should be at
Chili's er what the [ __ ] what is it
doing here
yeah yeah so this is a shirt thank you
where did covet 19 come from nothing is
certain but we know if that was involved
beginning today my limited-edition
warranties are now docked I thought more
this is the designer speak well deaf was
probably pissed a lot of people off yes
what a piss people off there was that
Spencer's is this still available to buy
one yeah it's all shut down his leg shut
down then the same designer I handed up
commenting on the that pose and said the
shirts were never produced and the
intent was never to profit from this
Lulu and the employee had absolutely no
involvement of course at this point I am
seeing all of this from a different
perspective the racial aspect of this
honestly had not occurred to me which is
clearly something I need to explore
further I apologize sincerely for any
offence be safe and healthy yeah I could
picture a lot of people being pissed off
right now like this is bad timing yeah
so people like one comment for example
on Twitter said there have been 100-plus
daily attacks on Asian Americans since
the start of Kovan 19 like to see people
adding to their hurt and racism hurts my
heart so that's like one response and
everyone was just like how I don't know
man like the comedy side just
immediately laughs but then I also
understand it's just bad timing right
now if I was him I double down nothing
to lose you [ __ ] up that hard yeah
nothing that it's not a big [ __ ] up he
lose his job at Lululemon though he's so
[ __ ]
oh yes yes he did yeah horse okay so how
do you double down from hey here's how
you done with that and there's a hit and
I hate myself okay I've only finally put
yourself in his mind so okay this
doesn't mean this is not Steve green
okay just say no every single comment
that I got I would say thank you come
again
Oh
just [ __ ] just just to [ __ ]
doubled that book that's what you do if
that's that's if that's all you got
if that's all you got you [ __ ] go for
it you [ __ ] you if you're in the ring
and you're already getting beat the [ __ ]
it might as well [ __ ] go on as well
yeah you might as well go out looking
like a champ
damn if you don't want to find a job at
least some gym someone's gonna hire a
men I like what you did there you know
somebody somewhere was in America [ __ ]
yeah
right some raises ethical at least some
business right out of yogurt shop
somewhere he's like yeah I like what you
did good job we need to support people
like you yeah exactly
you're one of us you're to tell a good
yeah I love that like he in the
description it kind of sound like who
knows where it came from but he has a
Chinese body of Chinese takeout Chinese
takeout box he designed it like that oh
so egregious isn't the English letters
like the Chinese letters too like by the
way everyone has blamed the bad stuff
but it looks like it actually came from
a [ __ ] lab like yeah I mean there's
even theory that it came from a lab in
the States and it was infected in
soldiers here and taken out out there
too there's just so many differences a
prominent theory that came from from the
Chinese government yeah that depends how
much country yeah yeah yeah it's all
[ __ ] up you know like sometimes like a
part of me I just get so frustrated with
like the not knowing of the truth like
with history and like things and like
[ __ ] no I just wish there was a book
that had the truth in it like you know
why they'll never be the truth because I
have an account of what happened and so
do you so let's say we both went to war
right there's TIFF land in Jabalia right
yeah what I perceive went down and what
you perceived went down is completely
different and who was the good guy and
bad guy is completely different so I
mean even Edwards known will tell you
that he feels like the people who
the quote-unquote deep state all
whatever you wanna call it the
government apparatus that never leaves
the guys who can't get fired they kind
of stay in the same place while
presidents come and go he feels that
they feel like they're doing it for the
greater good like it's the if they're
doing it for the good of the country all
that kind of [ __ ] so it's the same kind
of [ __ ] whereas like Harris they think
they're doing something oh yeah so you
can you can interrogate Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed and waterboard the [ __ ] out of
him and then threaten to waterboard
every one that or even worse tortured
people in in these black sites where we
torture terrorists all the time
and you could say it's for the greater
good but that's the scary thing right
that's where it gets scary for me is
like you're willing to do all that [ __ ]
to people with no rules no limits and
[ __ ] that so for the greater good and
what at what cost
like it's it's for the greater good of
the people the airlines had to get a lot
of money because they provide sag jobs
and like for the people we everyone all
the banks had to get bailed out and
stuff because you know because they're
taking how the heavy risks with all of
our money yeah but it's like damn why
are they doing that why do we let that
happen and why do we get no [ __ ]
kickback for the money that we all put
into the banks that they used to invest
and make money back we get none of that
kickback to us so why do they get
build-up the scam never stops the scam
just gets filtered somewhere else that's
why I want to be in power so I don't
feel like I'm getting cheated that's the
moon you just cheat other people yep
but if you're on the bottom you're
always getting cheated ways if you're
the middle class - you're always getting
cheated and I don't know NZ they they're
so genius that they make the poor people
in the middle class people fight against
each other upper middle class people
that day they're like that's a rich
person uh-huh no no well they make the
poor they make the poor and the the
upper poor fight against the middle
class guy and they call them the rich
yeah they call the middle class the rich
which is nuts
the rich are like because he owns a BMW
oh that guy is rich that's what I'm
saying is like that's not even real rich
tax it 50% you're not the real risk nope
like
real rich don't get those tax because
they they have those six situations
where it's all assets and they don't and
they pay themselves a certain amount of
money and so they don't get those same
amount of taxes which you need to finish
the parasite movie Steve I can't wait
you got a thing I can't wait I know I
got twenty minutes and I had it I'm good
to have that lens of like looking at the
movie you're like [ __ ] this is
everything I've been talking about yes
that's the bestseller I've heard for
this movie by the way okay
it is a socio-economic movie good pitch
good embedded in a monster in the house
kind of is the mattress no not really
not really it's a parasite in the house
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]